[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous Bienvenue
c'est sence public votre rendez-vous de
débat et de reportage on est ensemble du
lundi au jeudi à 18h et 22h pour donner
du sens à l'actualité grâce à nos
invités experts et grâce à la rédaction
de Public Sénat et voici le sommaire de
ce 22 novembre c'est une étape majeure
dans le conflit Israël Hamas la promesse
de libération de 50 otage de
l'organisation terroriste en échange de
4 jours de trêve et de prisonniers
palestin qui est à la manœuvre des
négociations il y aura-t-il des Français
parmi les femmes et les enfants libérés
est-ce le premier signe d'une sortie de
crise on répond à toutes ces questions
dans une minute et puis pour notre
second débat volontairement décalé de
l'actualité je vous propose de revenir
sur cette affaire d'étoile de David
tagué sur les murs de Paris fin octobre
une affaire derrière laquelle plane
l'ombre de la
Russie pourquoi les intéressés n'ont-ils
pas fait l'objet de poursuit
de poursuite pénale pourquoi ont-ils
simplement été expulsés que savez-vous
de leur commanditair dont la presse
semble unanime à désigné les services de
renseignement russes d'autres actions
similaires de la part de ces mêmes
services ont-elles été identifié au
cours de ces dernières années quelle
forme prend cette ingérence russe
comment se défendre face aux opérations
de déstabilisation de la Russie mais
aussi d'autres puissances étrangères la
France est-elle enfin sortie de l'ère de
la réponse dans TR qu4 d'heure mais
d'abord donc les détails de l'accord
validé par le gouvernement israélien un
accord fragile Fabien REER c'est un
premier signe de répi après plus de 6
semaines de guerre
50 otages du Hamas des femmes et des
enfants doivent être libérés à partir de
jeudi en échange d'une trêve de 4 jours
dans les combats à Gaza et de la
libération de 150 prisonniers
palestiniens l'accord a été annoncé dans
la nuit de mercredi par le Qatar à la
manœuvre pour faire aboutir les
négociations un accord salué par
l'ensemble de la communauté
internationale de Washington à Pékin
mais dont l'annonce a été accueillie
avec des sentiments mitigés par la
population israélienne tout le monde a
beaucoup d'espoir surtout de voir les
enfants rentrer chez eux chaque personne
qui rentrera est très importante pour
nous mais notre crainte c'est que cette
trêve ne donne au Hamas le temps de se
réorganisé et qu'au bout du compte on le
paye avec encore plus de soldats
israéliens tués quel que 240 personnes
ont été capturées et prises en otage
lors de l'attaque du Hamas contre Israël
le 7 octobre parmi elles au moins h
otages français pour leur famille
l'espoir qu'il soit parmi ceux qui
seront libérés est immense nous espérons
qu'il y a des Français parmi eux et même
si possible parmi le premier groupe qui
va être libéré puisque ce doit être
grâce à une trêve des libérations étager
nous l'espérons j'ajoute nous y
travaillons nous travaillons
d'arrachepied c'est vraiment notre
première priorité depuis le début
l'accord entre l'État hébreu et le Hamas
prévoit de nouvelles trêves de 24 heures
à chaque fois que 10 otages
supplémentaires seront libérés côté
palestinien la majorité des candidats à
une libération sont des adolescents
selon une liste publiée par Israël
mercredi on dévoile les dessous d'un
accord fragile avec Laurent saahim
bonsoir vous êtes journaliste ancienne
correspondante en Israël et aux
États-Unis B Nabli bonsoir et bienvenue
à vous professeur de droit pe Paris 12
consultant international au cabin lisias
partenire et vous publiez relations
internationales droit théorie et
pratique aux éditions pédon David
rigoulerose bonsoir et bienvenue
chercheur à l'Institut français
d'analyse stratégique chercheur associé
à Liris et rédacteur en chef de la revue
Orient stratégique j'accueille également
en duplexe depuis télaviv Julien Balou
qui est spécialiste de la société
israélienne ancien journaliste ancien
porte-parole de tsal bonsoir à vous
Julien et Mathieu croissandau
éditorialiste politique bonsoir B
bonsoir Laurence tout le monde espère
les les premières libérations d'otage
demain est-ce garanti ou faut-il rester
prudent en a titré sur un accord fragile
alors je vais avoir l'attitude
américaine et les diplomates américains
en l'occurrence Anthony blinken mais
aussi le président Biden ne cesse de
répéter que tant que ce n'est pas fait
rien n'est fait donc il faut rester
prudent visiblement il y a un accord qui
a été trouvé mais on ne les a pas encore
vu ces otages c'est un accord qui va
s'étaler sur plusieurs jours qui va
comme Catherine Colona vient de le Rapp
h
é jours desoupes de qui dev 10 par jour
et c'est très long dans la situation
internationale actuelle 4 jours tout
peut arriver que se passe-t-il si d'un
seul coup il y a des attaques au nord
d'Israël que se passe-t-il si des
groupes ne veulent pas de cet accord
pour le moment il y a un accord qui a
été trouvé les otages sont toujours à
Gaza donc quel condition avec une
logistique très compliquée vont-ils
sortir on le verra restons prudent c'est
une bonne nouvelle mais c'est pas fait
ce n'est pas fait David rigouerose il
faut aussi rappeler qu'il y a une action
juridique possible en Israël y a de
toute façon un délai de 24 heur c'est ce
qu'on a compris oui déjà il y avait il
fallait obtenir l'aval du cabinet de
guerre he pour pour avaliser le enfin
pour finaliser l'accord et puis
effectivement il y a un recours possible
pour les familles c'est très compliqué
compte tenu du fait qu'il s'agit d'une
organation terroriste et que ils peuvent
effectivement faire un recours mais mais
il est vraisemblable que que ça sera de
toute façon c'est paramètré pour que le
l'accord soit quand même effectif donc
vraisemblablement il devrait être mis en
œuvre à partir de demain à partir de
demain matin c'est en tout cas les
informations qu'on a en cette fin
d'après-midi B nabl comment cette
question des otages elle est devenue ou
redevenue prioritaire ça c'est aussi
intéressant à à analyser à décrypter oui
c'est clair en fait il y a deux
dimensions j'ai d'abord il y a une
dimension internationale dans la mesure
où l'accord est aussi le produit d'un
dispositif diplomatique puisqu'il y a
différentes différentes parties
prenantes c'est pas Israël et le Hamas
qui seul ont réussi à conclure un tel
accord on parlera du rôle du Qatar en
détail un peu plus tard dans su par les
États-Unis et l'Égypte on y reviendra et
puis du point de vue interne ce qui est
remarquable c'est la montée en puissance
de cette question au sein de l'opinion
publique israélienne sachant que dans un
tout premier temps le gouvernement
israélien sa tendance sa propension
était de placer finalement cette
question à un statut finalement
secondaire la priorité c'était
l'offensive militaire avec l'objectif de
destruction du Hamas puis
progressivement il y a eu cette donnée à
la fois humanitaire et qui qui renvoie
aussi à la capacité des familles de
s'organiser à se faire entendre
euh ce qu'ils ont réussi à faire y
compris à l'échelle internationale parce
qu'il y a beaucoup de binationaux et là
pour le coup le gouvernement israélien
n'a pas pu faire fille de cette réalité
làà et ça a pu participer à l'accord
d'aujourdhui ouais Julien baloule cet
accord est-ce qu' fait l'unanimité alors
on a parlé du cabinet de guerre il y a
il y a l'aspect politique mais même au
sein de l'armée israélienne est-ce qu'il
y a eu des bois qui se sont élevés pour
dire non c'est trop tôt ou non ça va
permettre au ramas de euh de de
regrouper ses
forces oui je je suis assez d' d'accord
avec tout ce qui a été dit en plateau
hein sur le fait que c'était pas
vraiment au début la priorité puisqueau
début la priorité c'était vraiment qu'il
fallait donner un gros coup
militairement au Hamas et euh
l'estimation au sein des service de
sécurité était que tant que le ne sera
pas sous une pression militaire on ne
pourra pas être en position de négocier
avec eux un accord visant à la
libération des
otages donc c'est vrai que ce qui a été
dit est très vrai il y a eu une bataille
de l'opinion pour convaincre pour
l'opinion publique israélienne
soutiennent un éventuel accord pour
également un rassemblement ce weekend
avec 30000 personnes à Jérusalem c'est
important en temps de guerre et d'un
point de vue disons crainte sécuritaire
le traumatisme si vous voulez c'est la
libération de Guil Chalit en 201 11 à
l'époque Israël libère plus de 1000
palestiniens dont certains avaient du
sang sur les mains et dont beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup sont devenus des
terroristes par la suite dont certains
ont participé au pogrom du 17 octobre là
à l'heure actuelle dans le dans le
premier en tout cas le premier premier
groupe de Palestiniens qui va être
libéré il y a personne qui a été
condamné pour avoir du sens sur les
mains pour avoir commis un attentat il y
en a qui ont participé il y en a par
exemple jetai des jéicans descens sur
les soldat qu' on tenté d'All Tattaquer
mais personne encore n de s sur les
mains donc c'est plus acceptable pour
l'opinion ou je je vous repose la
question vous avez pas tout à fait
répondu sur des des voix discordantes au
sein de l'armée sur la décision de de de
passer cet accord et finalement
d'ctroyer 4 jours de trêve ouais alors
ouais exactement c'est vous avez raison
de de me reprendre là-dessus il y a deux
choses certains estiment un je vous
disais la crainte que certains de
libérer rejoindre le terrorisme et sur
les jour de trait vous avez raison
certains estiment que à partir du moment
où Israël cessera les combats stoppera
ou suspendra ça sera très difficile de
reprendre derrière pourquoi parce que
d'une part
les familles qui n'uront pas vu leurs
proches libérés vont dire mais et nous
pourquoi est-ce que vous arrêtez
maintenant vu que normalement il y a 10
libérés après 24 heures de chaque tra de
trêve on l'a dit un instant donc les
familles des otages qui restent à
l'arrière vont vont vont mettre la
pression de deux au niveau de la
pression internationale lorsqu'on va
enfin s'habituer à desacalmies lorsque
tous les Israéliens pourront vivre dans
le calme et que les Palestiniens de Gaza
pourront accéder à toute la l
internationale et cetera et cetera ça va
êre très dur de reprendre le le les
combats et d'autre part faut savoir que
jusqu'à présent l'essentiel des des
opérations armée israëlen so était sur
le nord de la bande de Gaza or on sait
que bah fatalement l'essentiel du khamas
s'est déplacé après maintenant vers le
sud et donc l'armée a dit on n pas
terminer le travail si l'objectif est de
détruire le Hamas l'objectif n'est pas
atteint merci beaucoup Julien Balou je
vous redonnerai évidemment la parole
plusieurs fois dans dans dans ce débat
David rigoler rose c'est quoi la
stratégie du ramas
50 totage je dis on le sait il y en a
autour de 240 donc bah elle est elle est
très élaborée parce qu'initialement il y
avait le la demande ce qui était
maximaliste c'était de libérer
tous les prisonniers palestiniens
incarcérés en Israël et puis ils ont
changé de posture et ils sont rentré
dans une logique transactionnelle par
aigrainage alors justement l'intérêt on
peut penser que c'était parce qu'ils
avaient été mis en position de faiblesse
sous la pression militaire de
l'opération ce qui n'est pas exclu mais
en même temps c'est très élaboré parce
que ils vont mettre le gouvernement au
pied du mur par rapport aux familles en
en égrainant justement successivement
avec le principe de la reconductibilité
potentielle de la
qui permet au Hamas potentiellement de
se réorganiser c'est bien ça c'était le
problème du délai était essentiel c'est
pour ça que ça a été les 5 jours ont été
refusé 3 c'était insuffisant 5 c'était
trop pour tal donc on a coupé la PO en
deux en acceptant 4 mais évidemment le
le ramas de toute façon n'a pas
l'intention de libérer tous les otages
parce que il se désaisit à ce moment-là
d'un joker donc c'est c'est in
contestablement c'est une pression qui
est mise sur la société israélienne mais
sur le gouvernement israélien et il y a
une logique du faible au fort mais qui
peut être efficace en diluant sur le
temps Laurence sa que c'est on des
conditions de détention de C de ces
otages certainement pas facile de
répondre à la question c'est pas facile
mais il y a une femme qui a parlé qui a
été libérée qui est une vieille dame de
85 ans qui a tenu une conférence de
presse et qui a expliqué de manière très
précise son expérience alors on ne sait
pas si c'est l'expérience de tous les
otages parce qu'on ne sait pas
évidemment si tous les otages ont été au
même endroit beaucoup disent qu'ils ont
été séparés qu'ils ont été dans des T
différents ou des lieux différents en
tout cas cette vieille dame racontait
comment elle avait marché pieds nus avec
des gens qui avaient des bâtons qui
hurlaiit sur elle qui tapait sur elle
qu'elle a marché plusieurs kilomètres
que quand elle est arrivée dans les
tunnels elle est descendue très
profondément dans le tunnel qu'elle a
été mise dans une salle qui était
entièrement préparé avec des lits qui
étaient déjà là ce qui prouve le niveau
de sophistication elle racontait qu'elle
avait un repas par jour avec de la pita
des concombres qui étaient donné et
qu'elle mangeait en même temps que ses
ravisseurs elle racontait ai aussi
qu'elle avait accès à des médicaments et
que un médecin venait deux à trois fois
par semaine vérifier l'état de santé des
otages mais elle racontait quand même
que ces conditions de détention était
extrêmement difficile et bien évidemment
elle est toujours hospitalisée à l'heure
actuelle et sa famille dit qu'elle est
encore à 85 ans traumatisé par ce qui
s'est passé oui vous racontez notamment
ces histoires là sur dans votre
newsletter aotage aotage sans frontière
je vis qu'on parle des prisonniers
palestiniens puis qu'on l'a bien compris
dans cet accord il y a les jours de
trêve et aussi la libération de de
prisonniers en je vous propose de
regarder ces chiffres qui nous viennent
d'une ONG israélienne qui s'appelle
amoked 6700 prisonniers dont 2300
personnes condamné 2300 en attente de
procès et 2000 en détention
administrative donc ce sont a priori les
personnes qui sont détenues sans charge
pour une période indéfinie B na est-ce
qu'il y a depuis se octobre beaucoup de
de ces arrestations préventives c'est le
terme qu'il faut employé oui en
particulier du côté de laass Jordanie
mais c'est pas nouveau pour le coup et
et il y a un élément très intéressant ça
s accéléré depuis le 7 octobre euh enfin
officiellement ça vise des membres du
Hamas des gens qui seraient liés au
Hamas le problème c'est que encore une
fois le conflit dans sa dans sa
complexité n'a pas débuté le 7 octobre
et le phénomène dont vous parlez en
particulier celui de la détention
administrative c'est-à-dire finalement
comme vous l'avez dit une détention sans
charge claire et sans garantie d'un
procès équitableah relève d'une justice
arbitraire qui n'est pas digne d'un état
de droit démocratique et et là c'est un
élément tout à fait signifiant parce que
on ne peut comprendre cette réalité là
que si on garde à l'esprit qu'on a à
faire à un état de droit tel qu'il se
présente mais qui a un État colonial
aussi et peut-être même d'abord et avant
tout dans ses rapports avec les
Palestiniens alors et comment c'est vécu
donc concrètement par les Palestiniens
ben c'est vécu enfin ces prisonniers
sont perçus comme bah des ut d'une
certaine manière je parle des des
prisonniers qui relèvent de la détention
administrative dans la mesure on ne sait
pas ce qu'ils ont fait il n'y a pas de
preuve de leur de leur responsabilité
pénale donc là il y a un vrai élément
intéressant parce que vous aviez posé la
question de savoir mais que fait le
Hamas bah côté israélien aussi a une
forme d'instrumentalisation de ces
personnes détenues arbitrairement
notamment à l'occasion de de tes
négociation la alors moi je suis pas
tout à fait d'accord avec vous parce que
je crois que être capturé quand on est
dans sa maison en train de prendre son
petit- déjeuner et qu'on est emmené de
forces sur une moto avec comme cette
dame de 85 ans le décrivait des gens qui
vous tapent avec des bâtons et qui vous
font marcher pieds nus quand on est un
civil c'est pas du tout pareil que quand
vous êtes arrêté dans une manifestation
parce que vous jetez des pierres il y a
un problème évidemment de détention et
de condition de détention fait par
l'armée israélienne récemment il y a eu
en tout cas une offensive en six
Jordanie importantes des forces
spéciales israéliennes qui a basé sur
sur des renseignements sont allés dans
des lieux comme tourkarem et on sait
historiquement depuis 2003 2004 2006 et
même avant et même 2014 que tourkarem il
y a eu beaucoup beaucoup de cellules qui
se créaient pour faire des attentats
contre Israël donc vous dites quoi c'est
pas forcément arbitraire c'est ce que
j'entends en fait y a des opérations
ciblé pour essayer de démantel des
cellules prêtes à commettre des attentat
en Israël c'est pas nouveau après
comment ces raides se sont sont opérés
on peut critiquer la manière dont les
Israéliens opèent mais pour les
Israéliens c'est aussi une manière de se
protéger contre des attentats en
arrêtant des gens et ils sont persuadés
que ces gens pourraient commettre des
attent c un peu l'argument des
États-Unis avec Guantanamo quand même
alors Guantanamo c'est différent oui
c'était préventif parfois avec des
charges ou sang parfois c'est c'est
c'est pas la même
chose c'est une zone de non droit encore
une fois est-ce que c'est une limite de
la démocratie israélienne on peut se
poser la question qu même je redonne la
parole à ensuite Julien Bou veut
intervenir non seulement ça relève d'une
justice préventive mais Perre je dirais
presque c'est que il y a pas de garantie
de procès les gens sont jetés en prison
savent pas quand est-ce qu'ils vont être
jugés et ils ne savent pas pourquoi ils
sont emprisonné donc c'est quand même
une logique quand même
qui justement puis je voudrais pas qu'on
y passe non plus trop de temps parce
qu'il y a beaucoup de thématique à
aborder une rationalité qui n'est pas
celle de l'État de droit tout simplement
allez Julien Bou intervenir là-dessus
répondre peut-être
à je vais êre je vais être très précis
et très court faut juste prendre en
compte on peut pas comparer ça à
guentanomo déjà guentanomo c'était je
rappelle le Niger qui ne se passait pas
à 10 km de Washington ou à 30 km de
Washington là n parle d'une menace
terroriste qui est à 50 minutes de ma
maison il a de personnes qui peuvent se
faire exploser dans l'AB de bus en bas
de chez moi c'est une menace qui est
bien plus concrète donc c'est pas tout à
fait comparable pour d'un part d'autre
part les arrestations administratives et
que Don dont vous parlez sont limité
dans le
temps loin de moi l'idée de défendre
certaine politique en jardanier contre
laquelle je me suis exprimé pour contre
laquelle je manifester mais soyons tout
de même précis ce n'est pas guantonamo
c'est une vraie menace throiste qui est
présente à quelques kilomètres d' notre
maison à quelques notre maison et c'est
limité dans le temps euh merci Julien
baloule on va parler du rôle du Qatar
comme promis c'est aussi un aspect
important de ce de de ce débat et je
vous propose d'entendre pour lancer ce
chapitre la réaction du Premier ministre
alors c'était il y a 3 jours il parlait
des négociations en
cours nous nous sommes concentrés sur
ces négociations au cours des qu ou 5
dernières semaines nous avons essayé
tous les moyens possibles afin de
garantir la libération des civils nous
traitons tous les êtres humains de la
même manière les civils sont des civils
qu'il soit du côté israélien ou du côté
palestinien on va évidemment continuer
de de rester prudent cette cette fin
d'aprèsmidi il y a pas encore eu de de
libération d'otage on n pas encore vu
les premiers otages sortir de la bande
de Gaza mais quand même David rigoler
rose ça marque une forme de victoire
pour le Qatar ce qui est en train de se
passer ah le Qatar a mis beaucoup de son
crédit dans dans le processus de
négociation c'est contestable d'abord
les premières les premières libération
étai aussi le fruit de négociation mené
sous la Louette du Qatar et le Qatar est
objectivement incontournable tout le
monde se tourne vers le Qatar tout
simplement parce qu'il est en mesure de
pas parler avec toutes les parties et de
parler directement non pas indirectement
mais directement il peut parler
directement avec le ramas parce qu'
bureau politique qui est à dois avec
Ismaël enet donc il a un contact
personnel il parle évidemment aussi avec
les Israéliens parce que faut faut
rappeler quand même qu'il avait un
accord tacite
pour les 30 millions de dollars par mois
qui arrivaient dans la bande de Gaza
dans l'enclab avant évidemment avant le
7 octobre oui le Qatar finançait le
payit les les fonctionnaires
Palestiniens et et les infrastructures
médicales civiles et C avec avec avec
l'aval israélien ça arrangit tout le
monde d'une certaine manière et en plus
le Qatar a un lien privilégié avec les
États-Unis puisque les États-Unis ont la
Une des plus principales bases sur au
Qatar qui s'appelle l'usncom qui qui est
sur la la zone Moyen-Orient Asie
centrale et donc et c'est un partenaire
stratégique privilégié donc évidemment
le Qatar est au centre bah de toutes les
attentions cont tenu des des
possibilités qu'on lui attribue qui ne
sont pas négligebles évidemment et et
donc qui se fait fort effectivement de
de faire valoir son rôle incontournable
h alur Saim les liens entre le Qatar et
les États-Unis ce sont d'abord des liens
de euh de
business où ça permet aussi de faire
beaucoup de politique quoi VO que
ÉtatsUnis une expression qui est
toujours rappelée par les diplomate
money Sting les Qatar c'est des gens
extrêmement riches donc évidemment on va
pas se fâcher d'un point de vue
américain avec ces gens-là mais ce qu'il
faut rappeler c'est quand même le rôle
assez ambigu du Qatar là-dessus à la
fois le leader du Hamas vit au Qatar et
a fait des conférences de presse et se
montrre régulièrement depuis le Qatar et
en même temps le Qatar est un acteur
extrêmement important dans la
négociation des otages il y a aussi
l'Égypte qui est extrêmement important
avec on le sait des négociateurs il y a
une petite information que j'ai apprise
il y a des négociateurs qui sont en
Égypte qui ont écrit sur des bouts de
papier des mots reçus de la part de
certains gouvernements pour les faire
passer sur papier par des négociateurs
qui connaissaient le Hamas qui venaient
et qui transport ces morceaux de papier
pour les faire passer dans les tunnels
pour dire voilà ce qui se passe et donc
on est en direct pratiquement dans une
négociation où il y a beaucoup de
secrets beaucoup de diplomatie parallèle
beaucoup de spin beaucoup de
communication avec regardez dans cette
direction mais ne regardez pas dans
cette direction beaucoup de choses qu'on
ne sait pas pour le moment et aussi le
proche orient c'est-à-dire des gens qui
viennent prendre des bouts de papier
pour les transporter et les mettre dans
les tunnels quand vous dites beaucoup de
spin quoi bah beaucoup de spin
c'est-à-dire que par exemple moi je
pense que le Qatar on en a beaucoup
parlé mais qu' peut y avoir aussi dans
la région des pays où il s'est passé des
réunions dont on a beaucoup moins parlé
et donc c'est toujours le spin
c'est-à-dire ah ben regardez là regardez
ce verre regardez tout se passe là et ça
empêche beaucoup de journalistes curieux
de regarder ailleurs par exemple il y a
pas mal de gens qui pensent qu'il y a
des négociations qui se sont passées
aussi dans le Sultana
Doman on aurait pu imaginer que le Qatar
allait être une aussi dans dans dans
dans les récriminations nées de des
attaques terroristes du du 7 octobre on
comprend pourquoi ça n'est pas arrivé
oui c'est clair que si on a si on porte
un regard un peu simpliste un peu
maniquéen sur ce conflit on se dit bah à
partir du moment où le le Hamas branche
politique siège de faitte à DOA et bien
le Qatar est un complice du Hamas bah le
raisonnement enfin ce raisonnement ne se
vérifie pas du point de vue géopolitique
parce que les différents protagonistes
sont liés et jouent à des jeux beaucoup
plus complexes que des jeux univoques ou
allant dans un seul sens et pour le coup
souligner cette ambivalence du Qatar qui
est réelle naturellement c'est aussi
souligner l'ambivalence de ses
partenaires les États-Unis et Israël en
particulierou il fallait surtout pas
trop l'attaquer pour pouvoir se pour
pouvoir l'utiliser ne pas griller ce cet
axe de négociation est-ce que c'est ça
alors c'est plus intéressant du côté
israélien pour parce que ça va prendre
de mon point de vue une proportion de
politique intérieure parce que cette
dimensionl va va contribuer à l'après au
débat sur l'après pourquoi parce que
beaucoup d'Israéliens je pense ont
découvert finalement la manière dont
Benjamin netanahou a contribué
finalement au fait de pouvoir financer
le Hamas pour qu'il puisse gérer
euh Gaza et neutraliser d'autant mieux
l'Autorité palestinienne afin que Infiné
l'option d'un d'un État palestinien ne
puisse pas exister que ce jeu là ce
raisonnement là finalement a contribué à
la catastrophe du 7 octobre et donc il y
a une responsabilité politique de tous
les protagonistes israéliens qui ont
misé sur le Hamas pour mieux tuer dans
l'œuf l'option ou la perspective d'un
État palestinien et je pense que ça va
ça risque d'être un élément du
débat politique intérieure
israélien question de Ben mais pourquoi
le Qatar fournit le git et le couvert as
mais parce c'est une manière de de peser
précisément parce que est-ce qu'il
partage est-ce qu'il partage les
objectif du Hamas est-ce que parce que
ils sont pas obligés de les accueillir
ni de les financer à coup parce que là
où ils ont une particularité le le Qatar
par rapport à à d'autres acteurs
régionaux c'est qu'il ils croient ils
ont continué à croire que le conflit
israëlo-palestinien avait de la valeur
stratégique ce ce que ne pensaient plus
les autres protagonist il ne partage
aucun objectif du Hamas c'est juste par
le choix de peser dans les négociations
internationalesê moins
stratégiqueidéologique peutê
idologiquei il relève de de de d'une
d'une idéologie islamiste formellement
mais c'est pas ce qui va expliquer un
tel engagement du côté du Qatar non le
Qatar a vu un vide politique qu'ils ont
comblé et ce vide c'était la question du
du enfin la question palestinienne à
laquelle plus personne ne voulait
s'impliquer ils se sont dit si on s que
on aura un levier pour peser d'autant
plus dans dans le tout le monde prendre
la parole sur ce thème ensuite on parle
des otages binationaux Laurence sa pour
commencer David Riol très rapidement
lorsque vous dites et vous le rappelez
souvent dans vos arguments Benjamin
Benyamin netanahou est responsable de la
montée du Hamas et de ce qui s'est passé
et d'une certaine manière est complice
d'avoir installé le Hamas et cetera moi
je voudrais simplement rappeler de fait
le premier c'est que le Hamas a été élu
démocratiquement en 2006 avec une
population qui était exent et qui voyait
dans le Hamas qui finançait des mosquées
des écoles des hôpitaux un moyen
d'essayer de faire quelque chose de Gaza
et la deuxième chose et vous ne parlez
jamais de ça c'est la corruption
palestinienne il y a des dizaines de non
il y a quand même beaucoup j'étais pas
là donc je vous prê de m'excuser mais en
tout cas la corruption palestinienne et
ces dizaines de millions d'euros de
dollars qui sont arrivés via le Qatar
via d'autres actcteur et qui n'ont pas
été utilisés par les Palestiniens et la
responsabilité de l'auto de l'Autorité
palestinienne est flagrante là-dessus ce
sera d'ailleurs un problème parce que le
Hamas dans sa campagne de 2006 avait
fait campagne là-dessus en disant les
dirigeants palestiniens ne sont plus
crédibles ils ont détourné l'argent donc
votez pour nous parce que nous nous
allons nous intéresser à vos problème de
la vie quotidienne et ça pose une
question à laquelle on va essayer de
répondre un peu plus tard dans ce débat
de qui pour représenter les Palestiniens
dans une éventuelle sortie de crise
David rolose oui alors il il y a le
volet pales la problématique
palestinienne mais il y a aussi le volet
islam politique pour répondre à votre
question puisque c'est pas contingent
c'est-à-dire que le le le Qatar a
préanté les dynamiques de l'islam
politique notamment à la faveur des
printemps arabes même si ça a
partiellement échoué mais d'où le lien
avec le ramas qui est une émanation
palestinienne de la mouvance des frères
fr musul des Frères musulmans oui donc
c'est c'est pas tout c'est pas du tout
hasardeux d'où les connexions d'ailleurs
avec Erdogan entre le Qatar et Erdogan
justement le Qatar est un soutien
déclaré c'est pas c'est pas caché c'est
pas occulte hein sur le plan idéologique
de de l'islam politique euh en
contre-point justement du wahabisme et
cetera saoudien comprêé effectivement
financier puisque j'évoqué le soutien et
puis médiatique avec aljzira donc c'est
pas c'est pas du tout accidentel et et
de de fait ça ça fait ça met le CTIN
dans une situation d'exception par
rapport aux autres pays effectivement de
de la région qui sont engagés dans une
dans une un conflit
antifrériste d'où l'isolement du Qatar à
partir de 2017 pendant plusieurs années
justement parce qu'il était stigmatisé
comme à tort ou à raison mais le sponsor
de la mouvance des frères donc si je
résume proximité je veux dire
idéologique pour pour simplifier et
intérêt stratégique il y a il y a il y a
il y a voilà c'est vos deux arguments
finalement se rejoign on va parler de de
de ces otages euh binationaux euh
évidemment leur sort est également au
cœur de ces négociations il y a
notamment h français parmi eux au moins
8 Français parmi eux Mathieu on va
s'intéresser à la diplomatie française
est-ce qu'on peut parler d'un manque de
lisibilité mais en tout cas un paradoxe
c'est qu'ils ont jamais été aussi
nombreux à s'emmêler et la France n'a
jamais donné l'impression de peser aussi
peu sur la marche du monde vous me direz
ceci pour expliquer cela mais nous
sommes quand même à un moment crucial où
l'influence de la France recule en
Afrique n'imprime plus vraiment au
ProcheOrient peine à convaincre parfois
en Europe et on se demande parfois si
elle parle vraiment d'une seule voix
alors à tout seigneurs tout honneur
c'est évidemment au présid président de
la République de donner le là la
politique étrangère ça fait partie de ce
que Jacques chabonmaelait le domaine
réservé mais en pratique il l' conduit
pas non plus tout seul et il s'appuie
généralement sur un ministre qu'il a
choisi et sur ses services c'est-à-dire
le Kor le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est
que Emmanuel Macron n'est pas des plus
partageurs avec sa ministre Catherine
Colona la diplomate française ainsi
enfin la diplomatie française en tout
cas a découvert avec stupeur par exemple
la proposition présidentielle vous
souvenez de coalition internationale
contre le Hamas qui a fait long feu tout
comme elle n'a pas compris la diplomatie
fr fr un soutien jugé trop appuyé à
Israël mal passé dans les capitales
arabes plusieurs ambassadeurs s'en sont
d'ailleurs émus dans une dans une lettre
que a révélé le Figaro la semaine
dernière est-ce que ça veut dire que le
courant passe mal entre Emmanuel Macron
et sa ministre alors oui et pourquoi
d'abord parce que c'est pas sa nature
Emmanuel Macron il aime le contact
direct de chef d'État à chef d'État
ensuite il y a traditionnellement des
rivalités entre les diplotes de l'Élysée
et le koret les diplôes de l'Élysée ne
se privant pas de savonner la planche de
Catherine
Colona bien sûr sans le dire enfin
Emmanuel Macron juge que sa ministre
n'imprime pas dans les médias Catherine
Colona pourtant une diplomate chevronné
elle donne pas dans le spectaculaire
c'est vrai c'est pas des numéros de
claquette à la télé mais elle rappelle
toujours avec une grande clarteté et une
grande précision la position de la
France mais tout ça fait sans doute un
peu trop ancien monde pour pour Emmanuel
Macron dernière humiliation en date le
président de la République a envoyer au
Proche Orient le ministre de la Défense
Sébastien Lecornu qui est un de ses très
proches alors on pourrait ce tableau en
mentionnant en plus l'activité dans la
région de jeanvre ledriant qui ancien
ministre de la Défense ancien ministre
des Affaires étrangères représentant
personnel du Président de la République
au Liban tout ça donne une impression
parfois de de concert de soliste ou de
polyphonie et pas forcément d'orchestre
symphonique en tout cas pas de quoi
déstabiliser Catherine Colona si on la
croit on lui demandait ce matin sur
France interre s'il y avait deux
ministres écouté sa réponse non il y a
des ministres qui travaillent pour la
France pour les intérêts de la France
sous la conduite du président de la
République je suis allé moi-même trois
fois dans la région la dernière fois il
y a une quinzaine de jours le ministre
des Armées y est retourné a vu les mêmes
pays mais d'autres interlocuteurs sur la
même ligne pour poursuivre les mêmes
efforts et ben c'est ce qu'on appelle
une réponse diplomatique diplomatique
effectivement merci Mathieu je voudrais
qu'on qu'on s'intéresse au au sort des
otages français B na on a beaucoup parlé
du Qatar là quelles sont les relations
de la France avec le Qatar et est-ce que
ça peut nous permettre d'espérer que
certains otages binationaux français
soient dans dans les premiers
libérés on a une de bonnes relations
diplomatiques avec le Qatar euh dans les
deux sens je dirais le le la France est
un producteur et un vendeur d'armes euh
choyé du côté du Qatar et le Qatar est
choyi également par notre législation du
point de vue de de ses capacités
d'investissement dans nos dans notre
économie donc il y a il y a
véritablement là une vraie complicité
qui s'est nouée avec les des années qui
remonte grosso modo aux années
Sarkozi et et ça n'a jamais été remis en
cause en fait une vraie continuité même
même durant le quinquen de François
Hollande et donc ça peut être utile en
ce moment ah ben oui bien sûr dans la
mesure où derrière les amb enfin pas les
ambivalence l'apparente l'apparente
contradiction de notre ligne durant
durant durant cette séquence à a
perturbé les relations bilatérales entre
président Macron et le Premier ministre
netaniaou parce que finalement c'est pas
très lisible finalement notre position
même s'il y a des mots très forts qui
ont été prononcés dès l'ors qu'il sont
prononcés successivement mais pas dans
la même phrase on ne comprend vraiment
plus très bien sur quel pied fonctionne
ou marche notre diplomatie et donc la
relation avec Israël est
traditionnellement un peu complexe mais
là pour le coup elle est pas elle est
pas elle est pas très claire elle est
pas au beau fixe et tant mieux si on on
a un partenaire qui est à la fois très
impliqué dans les négociations et avec
lesquels pour le coup notre relation est
beaucoup plus claire également ouais
Julien baloule est-ce que on sait est-ce
qu'on a quelques noms qui sont déjà
sorti de des premiers otages qui
pourraient être libérés dans les
prochaines heures alors justement il y a
un instant le gouvernement israélien
annoncé qu'il n'annoncerit pas ce soir
la liste des noms des otages qui seront
libérés pour une simple raison c'est
qu'il ne veut pas donner de faux espoir
et jouer avec les ner des famill ils ont
dit tant que nous récons pas ne
récupérons pas les otages et que nous
n'avons pas la l'identification précise
et for que les personnes qui sont face à
nous sont les otages qu' nous avez
annoncé nous ne l'annoncerons pas aux
familles toutefois toutefois comme on
sait que cette vague de libération
concernera les enfants des femmes des
mamans et des personnes âgées on a à peu
près une idée de quiil s'agit parmi le
il y a un enfant qui s'appelle etan qui
est un franco-israélien donc il pourrait
faire partie de cette première vague de
libération dès demain dans les premiè
dans les premires heures je ne sais pas
parce qu'on sait que ça va être fait en
plusieurs vagues dans les dans les
quatre prochains jours et je vous donne
une information qui qui vient de tomber
il a vraiment quelques minutes la Cour
suprême israélienne a rejeté le recours
contre l'accord très bien merci beaucoup
pour cette information effectivement
c'est l'une des premières questions
posées dans ce débat donc ce cet inconnu
on va dire juridique vient d'être levé
c'est important alors il y a beaucoup de
pays concernés évidemment on l'a déjà
dit plusieurs fois sur ce plateau
notamment les États-Unis le Premier
ministre israélien a remercié
directement le président américain pour
son application on écoute Benjamin
netanah ces derniers jours j'ai parlé à
notre ami Joe Biden et je lui ai demandé
de contribuer à améliorer le cadre qui
vous est proposé et il a été amélioré
pour inclure plus d'otage à moindre coût
ces discussions ont été fructueuses le
président Biden s'est impliqué dans ce
dossier et je l'en remercie Joe Biden
qui s'implique Laurence mais est-ce que
ça veut dire qu'il y aura plus
d'Américains parmi les otages libérés
voyez ce que je veux dire parce que
c'est c'est assez enfin j'essaie de me
mettre à la place des des familles qui
sont dans cette incertitude mais on va
compter combien d'otages binationaux
quel pays a réussi à faire libérer le
plus
d'otage et on est dans une année
électorale présidentielle aux États-Unis
hein donc c'est évidemment Joe Biden
joue extrêmement gros sur cette question
des otages ils ont fait une priorité il
y a deux choses qui m'intéressent il y a
des otages c'est horrible à dire et je
pense que Julien Balou et pour tous ceux
qui s'intéressent aux otages le savent
il y a des otages symboliques il y a des
otages avec des images vidéos qui ont
marqué l'opinion publique et donc on
verra par exemple s'il y a une jeune
fille qui avait été traînée par les
cheveux avec son survêtement gris
ensanglanté elle s'appelle n Levi si
elle sortira ou pas pour en revenir aux
américains on ne sait pas combien
d'otage américains le Hamas détient il y
a eu des briefings qui ont été fait par
Jack Sullivan à la Maison Blanche par
Anthony blinken et les chiffres
diffèrent c'est-à-dire qu'il y en a un
qui parle de plus de 20 otages
américains il y en a un autre qui parle
de plus de 10 otages américains moi ce
que je retiens c'est que au tout début
tout de suite après le 7 octobre il y a
deux femmes américaines une mère et sa
fille qui sont sorties elles ont pris un
avion immédiatement pour une banlieue de
Chicago EV vanstone depuis on ne les a
absolument pas entendu et c'était les
deux premières otages qui étaient sortis
avec une négociation au plus haut sommet
qui s'était passé entre
blinken les cataris les Égyptiens les
Israéliens et sur ces deux femmes cette
mère qui est esthéticienne peintre et sa
fille on ne sait rien elles ont été
condamnées au silence donc est-ce qu'il
y a une ngociation parallèle américaine
qui se fait sans que peut-être des
Israéliens soient au courant pour est-ce
que CIT un autre groupe que le RAM mais
il y a plein de choses qui se passent et
en tout cas pour d'un point de vue de
politique américaine Joe Biden joue très
gros sur la libération des otages
américains alors c'est dans ce ce
contexte d'incertitude d'attente que les
images des massacres du 7 octobre ont
été projeté hier soir au Sénat à
l'initiative de Roger kucci le président
du groupe d'amitié France Israël je
propose à audre vetaz de nous rejoindre
sur ce plateau bonsoir Audrey avec des
sénateurs qui sont sortis bouleversés de
cette de ce visionnage oui Thomas un
silence de plomb c'est ce que nous a
décrit notre collègue Jérôme Rabier qui
était présent à la sortie des sénateurs
qui quittent la salle marqué choqué
fermés comme vous pouvez le voir sur les
images qu'on va vous montrer ils sont 75
à avoir assisté à ces 55 minutes
d'horreur à H clos les téléphones
portables étaient bien évidemment
interdits je vais vous proposer
d'écouter une réaction c'est celle
d'Olivier il est sénateur de loise et
c'est le seul en fait à avoir accepté de
s'exprimer à chaud après le visionnage
mais j'ai simplement vu jusqu'ù l'homme
pouvait perdre l'âme ni plus ni moins
c'est il y a pas de mot voilà c'est
c'est pas des hommes qui ont fait ça
c'est
terrible en fait ce qui a le plus choqué
les sénateurs c'est la joie des
terroristes au moment des exactions
c'est aussi ce que retient le LR Francis
spinner pourtant il est avocat pénaliste
il a a vu des images d'autopsie il a
aussi vu les images des meurtres de
Mohamed Mera qui portait on s'en
souvient une caméra embarquée mais le
sentiment après la projection d'hier est
bien
différent ce qui est effrayant
évidemment dans ce que nous avons vu
hier c'est l'effet de masse
d'accumulation et surtout euh lorsqu'on
voit le crime mais lorsqu'on voit la
joie autour du crime je a il y a
quelqu'un qui a parlé et qui a dit que
c'était pas humain et je pense que
malheureusement c'est très humain quand
on
sort il faut éviter d'être dans la haine
parce que quand vous voyez ces images
vous comprenez l'envie de haine et de
vengeance donc on l'a dit cette
projection était à l'initiative de Roger
carucci et alors la question se pose he
sur la diffusion ou non de ces images
lui il a tenu à expliquer pourquoi il
avait organisé cette projection au
Sénat c'est la vérité vérité son sorti
sans voix complètement sonné céit effet
chocou oui mais la vérité est parfois
très Durre à vivre et c'était aussi là
encore pour que dans l'opinion on
n'oublie pas que le fait déclur le fait
déclencheur c'est un massacre barbare
qui s'est passé le 7 octobre et qu'on
n'est pas dans le côté on vous renvoie
do ADS non il y a quelqu'un qui a initié
tout cela et puis je termine avec une
information Thomas Roger carucci devrait
accompagner le président du Sénat et les
différents présidents de groupe en
Israël et peut-être a un déplacement qui
est prévu les 21 et 22 décembre merci
Audrey pour pour ces témoignage et ces
informations je voudrais qu'on se
projette maintenant dans dans dans
l'après dans ce qui peut se passer dans
les prochains jours dans les prochaines
semaines David Rigolet Rous je me je me
tourne vers vous parce que le le
traumatisme il faut mesurer le
traumatisme de du 7 octobre dans la
société israélienne est-ce que ça veut
dire que les soldats de TS ne sont pas
prêts de quitter la bande de Gaza si on
se projette dans l'a près c'est c'est
effectivement la question du jour
d'après avec un gros point
d'interrogation d'ailleurs il y a une
certaine confusion hein sur le ce qui
est envisagé y compris du côté israélien
puisque il y a il y a plusieurs scénaris
qui étaient qui sont mis sur la table
l'idée que il d'une occupation d'une
d'une tierce administration et cetera le
président Biden a dit qu'il ne qu'il ne
recommandait pas du tout donc c'est F
fémisé une une réoccupation parsal euh
que il était oui c'était après que oui
benan dit on va s'occuper de la sécurité
à G voà parce que il y a effectivement
l'enjeu sécuritaire c'est-à-dire ne pas
se remettre en situation de de pouvoir
revivre l'abomination du 7 octobre mais
en même temps c'est une c'est pas une
solution viable donc la question d'une
Autorité palestinienne et refus d'Israël
puisqueil considère que la la dite
autorité est disqualifiée ce qui ce qui
est vrai concrètement y compris au sein
de sa propre population d'où d'où la
formulation du président Joe Biden sur
une autorité palestinen revitalisé euh
c'est-à-dire alors selon des modalités
qui restent à déterminer le le fait que
l'ONU est renoncé à prendre en charge
l'enclave et puis alors évidemment le
scénario extrême qui ne sera pas toléré
par les Américains c'est l'expulsion euh
des de de la bande de Gaza puisque une
un une ministre notamment des
renseignements du gouvernement netanahou
a évoqué le fait que finalement la
meilleure solution ce serait que les P
Arab prennent en charge la le la
relocalisation plutôt que de
reconstruire la bande de Gaza ouais
allez il nous reste 2 minutes je
voudrais vous entendre une dernière fois
là et l'autre peut-être B Nabli pour
commencer euh effectivement ce est-ce
que ce c'est alors on espère que ça va
être une première libération d'otage
encore une fois cet accord nous semble
fragile est-ce que c'est la première
étape d'une sortie de crise est-ce qu'on
peut aller jusque- là si on s'entient
notamment aux dernières déclaration euh
du Premier ministre israélien pas du
tout enfin enfin lui pour lui après
cette séquence ce qui suit c'est la
guerre ouis donc euh il n'y a pas de
d'accord de paix en vue euh je ne parle
même pas d'un processus de paix hein je
parle vraiment de ce conflit pour lui on
termine 4 jours de trêve et on
recommence finalement les bombardements
euh sur Gaza bon euh c'est de mon point
de vue une forme d'impasse militaire et
politique qui n'est pas très surprenante
au regard de finalement de précédents le
problème c'est que ça ne donne pas de
perspective ni aux Israéliens ni au
Palestiniens et donc c'est peut-être ce
qui est le plus euh saisissant ouais
avec une question qui qui est liée à ce
que vous venez de dire l partir de de
quand les autorités israéliennes le
cabinet de guerre va pouvoir dire le le
ramasse est est exterminé ou est vous
voyez ce que je veux dire puce que c'est
l'objectif éradiqué l'objectif c'est ça
donc comment comment comment on le
prouve quoi c'est je vous faire en trois
points premièrement tant que les otages
ne sont pas libérés rien ne se passera
il va y avoir peut-être 50 otages
libérés sur les 4 jours qui arrivent il
en restera peut-être 200 voir plus parce
qu'on a pas le nombre précis du nombre
d'otage la libération des otages va
rester la priorité c'est le préalable
deuxè la carte on continue faire la
guerre pour mettreis pas gouvernement
américain je dis simplement que la
priorité va être la libération des
otages deuxièmement la carte qu'on voit
du Proche Orient qu'on connaît ce n'est
plus la carte qui sera dessinée en
janvier en février ou dans 6 mois c'est
une carte qui va être complètement
redessinée qui va être Faaite comment
personne ne le sait et troisè n'oublions
pas quand on a été sur le terrain ce que
les gens qui vivent au quotidien disent
toujours dans cette partie du monde ce
qu'on prévoit là-bas n'arrive jamais et
ce qu'on ne prévoit pas arrive toujours
voilà c'est ce que vous apprenez quand
vous êtes reporter que vous couvrez la
situation là-bas cette phrase alors
c'est toujours dit en anglais là
j'aiessayé de le traduire mais dans ma
tête je pense en
anglais merci beaucoup à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat ici et en duplexe
évidemment Julien balounab je rappelle
votre livre relation internationale
droit théorie et pratique qui est aux
éditions pédon et puis Laurence sain
votre newsletter aotage sans frontière
la prochaine prochain numéro paraît euh
demain à bientôt sur sur Public Sénat